Bonjour!
Il y a quelques années, j'avais dû expliquer
à une pote que non, le blason de sa ville
n'était pas un lion mais un léopard.
Quelle déception.
Si comme moi vous voulez vous la péter en
lisant les blasons des villes de vos amis,
cet épisode est fait pour vous!
Ah, oui, vous aurez peut-être remarqué que
j'ai changé de nom, parce qu'on ne va plus
se proposer de thème mensuel avec les Créatrices
du Tube.
Mais comme ça je continue de faire des épisodes
pépères dans mon canapé avec des jolies
images.
L'utilisation d'armes spécifiques pour identifier
un chevalier apparaît au XIIe siècle, en
raison du changement d'équipement militaire
de ces chevaliers.
En effet à cette époque se développent
les cottes de maille, et les casques couvrant
le visage.
Il devient donc nécessaire d'identifier autrement
les chefs et chevaliers, grâce à leurs écus
ou leur étendard, ou encore à un cimier
distinctif que les chevaliers portent au dessus
de leur casque lors des tournois pour faire
joli.
Et pour faire genre qu'ils sont plus grands.
On retrouve certaines armoiries avant le XIIe
siècle, comme sur la tapisserie de Bayeux
qui date de la fin du XIe siècle.
On parle alors d'emblèmes préhéraldiques:
ces emblèmes ne sont pas héréditaires,
et il est peu probables qu'ils aient été
permanents pour ceux qui les utilisaient.
Puisqu'à partir du XIIe siècle les armes,
ou armoiries, deviennent héréditaires, elles
deviennent un système d'identification des
personnes mais aussi des lignées.
Leur utilité est la même que celles des
sceaux, qui permettent d'identifier des documents
à une époque où la plupart des sujets étaient
illettrés.
On en arrive donc au terme d'héraldique,
qui est un dérivé de la fonction de «héraut»
sur laquelle nous reviendrons juste après.
L'héraldique désigne l'étude des armoiries,
et on la qualifie de «science héraldique»
à partir du XVIIe siècle.
Ah, et pour la faire court: le blason n'est
pas un synonyme d’armoiries: les armoiries,
ce sont les petits dessins sur le bouclier;
et le blason, ou blasonnement, c'est la description
de ces armoiries selon des termes bien précis.
Donc: à gauche ce sont des armoiries;
et à droite, c'est leur blason.
Les armoiries se révèlent particulièrement
utiles lors des tournois, des compétitions
amicales entre chevaliers.
Comme les chevaliers devaient montrer qu'ils
étaient courageux, dévoués et tout le bazar,
ils allaient de tournoi en tournoi pour montrer
à quel point ils étaient balèzes.
Les tournois étaient aussi l'occasion de
montrer leurs armoiries un peu partout pour
se faire connaître: ainsi ils accrochaient
leur bouclier à l'extérieur de leur lieu
d'habitation, et représentaient leurs armoiries
un peu partout: sur leur bouclier mais aussi
leurs vêtements, le harnachement de leurs
chevaux, leur tente, leur mug souvenir...
Mais évidemment, pour les pécores qui venaient
assister au tournoi (et même pour les personnes
de haut rang, ne nous mentons pas) ces armoiries
ne voulaient pas dire grand chose.
Pour les déchiffrer il fallait un maître,
un expert: le héraut.
Les hérauts, c'étaient ces mecs qui connaissent
tout le monde en soirée.
Ils deviennent à force de travail et de voyages
des experts en héraldique, et sont chargés
lors des tournois d'annoncer le chevalier
en énonçant son blason puis en le nommant.
Ils font donc office de maîtres de cérémonie,
mais aussi d'arbitres, ils vérifient que
personne ne combat sous les couleurs d'un
autre, que les armes de tout le monde sont
bien uniques, etc...
De manière un peu moins fun, si un chevalier
désire confier son testament à quelqu'un
avant le tournoi, c'est au héraut qu'il doit
s'adresser.
Leur rôle ne se limite pas aux tournois:
ils sont aussi employés par les personnages
importants comme messagers et ambassadeurs.
Lorsqu'ils sont en service, ils portent un
tabard, ou cotte d'armes, une sorte de tunique
en gros aux couleurs de leur maître.
Cette cotte d'armes les rend théoriquement
intouchables: ils sont libres de circuler
partout même dans les camps ennemis, n'ont
aucune valeur de rançon, et effectuent des
missions diplomatiques comme porter des déclarations
de guerre par exemple.
Toute attaque faite à leur encontre est une
attaque envers leur maître.
Comme ils s'y connaissent en héraldique,
ils sont également utiles lors des batailles:
on leur demande d'identifier les morts, les
captifs, pour savoir s'ils valent cher ou
pas, et il arrive parfois même que ce soient
les hérauts qui doivent trancher si la bataille
a été gagnée ou pas: c'est le cas lors
de la bataille d'Azincourt par exemple.
A partir du XIVe siècle, les hérauts établissent
des armoriaux: des ouvrages qui recensent
toutes les armoiries qu'ils connaissent.
Parce qu'il y en avait un paquet.
Dans les mémoires d'Olivier de la Marche,
qui vécut au XVe siècle, il estime qu'il
faut sept ans pour devenir héraut, le temps
d'acquérir assez de connaissances en la matière.
C'est aussi à partir de cette époque qu'ils
codifient l'héraldique avec tous ses termes
particuliers et ses règles.
En Angleterre, les hérauts sont réunis en
corporation par une charte royale de 1484,
et il leur arrive de faire des visites d'inspection
à travers le pays pour répertorier les armoiries
et régler les conflits.
Dans certains pays comme le Royaume-Uni, les
hérauts existent encore et ont pour rôle
de confirmer des armoiries utilisées depuis
longtemps par des familles sans qu'elles aient
été officialisées, ou bien attribuer et
concevoir de nouvelles armoiries.
Par exemple, le collège des Armes d'Angleterre
a accordé des armoiries à la famille Middleton
au moment du mariage de Kate Middleton en
2011.
La famille s'est vue attribuer des armes «D’azur
pâle et de gueules au chevron d'or coticé
d’argent, accompagné de trois glands d'or,
tigés et feuillés du même», et chaque
détail a un sens particulier: les trois
glands représentent les trois enfants, c'est
super flatteur dit comme ça, mais aussi la
région dans laquelle la famille a grandi
parce que c'est une région de glands...
Enfin, où il y a beaucoup de chênes.
Les chevrons d'argent représentent des collines
parce qu'ils adorent la nature, le chevron
d'or représente la mère de Kate dont le
nom de naissance est Goldsmith...
Bref, les armoiries ne sont pas juste là
pour faire joli mais ont souvent un sens plus
ou moins évident.
C'est ce que nous allons voir à présent.
On va surtout s'intéresser à l'écu ou bouclier,
parce que c'est la partie principale des armoiries,
et la seule qui soit indispensable.
Certaines armes sont décorées avec des petits
heaumes, des banderoles, etc...
Mais on ne va pas s'attarder là dessus.
Alors, pour commencer simplement: en langage
de l'héraldique, la gauche (senestre) et
la droite (dextre) doivent être prises du
point de vue de la personne qui tient le bouclier,
elles sont donc inversées par rapport à
d'habitude.
Le bouclier est aussi divisé en cinq régions
principales: le chef, le cœur, les flancs
dextre et sénestre et la pointe.
Ces régions renvoient à des parties du corps.
Puisqu'on est sur des histoire de gauche et
de droite: la dextre étant considérée
comme la direction la plus noble, n'en déplaise
aux gauchers, la plupart des emblèmes sont
dessinés tournés vers ce côté.
Passons aux couleurs à présent.
Il existe trois catégories de couleurs en
héraldique.
D'ailleurs en héraldique on ne parle pas
de couleurs, mais d'émaux.
Comme le noir, parce que le noir, c'est trop
emo.
Bref, les hérauts aiment bien les mots compliqués,
et c'est que le début.
Il y a d'abord les émaux qui font référence
à des couleurs: gueules pour rouge, azur
ou bleu céleste pour bleu, sable pour noir,
pourpre pour violet, tanné pour marron, sinople
pour vert, et orangé ou sanguine pour...
de l'orangé sanguinaire.
Ensuite il existe deux émaux issus de métaux:
or pour jaune et argent pour blanc.
On peut vraiment les représenter par de l'or
et de l'argent, mais ces pigments coûtent
cher alors ils sont plus souvent représentés
par du jaune et du blanc.
Et enfin, les émaux issus de fourrures:
l'hermine, avec toutes ses variations (contre-hermine,
contre-herminé) et le air ou vair, composé
de petites pièces en forme de clochettes.
Lui aussi a des variations, vairé, contre-vair,
menu-vair, beffroi-vair...
Par rapport à toutes ces couleurs, il y a
des règles à respecter: jamais de métal
sur métal, ni de couleur sur couleur, ni
de fourrure sur fourrure.
Bien sûr il y a des exceptions, comme les
armes de la ville de Jérusalem qui sont or
sur argent.
Quand des armoiries ne respectent pas cette
règle, elles sont dites «à enquerre».
Maintenant qu'on a vu les couleurs, passons
aux partitions de l'écu:
La couleur dans laquelle il est peint s'appelle
le champ.
Mais cet écu peut être divisé: on parle
alors de partitions.
Il peut être parti, écartelé en sautoir,
écartelé, gironné, tiercé en pairle, coupé,
tranché, taillé, mantelé...
Dit comme ça on dirait qu'on a bien fait
souffrir ce pauvre écu.
La division en quartiers, dans le cas d'armoiries
royales ou princières, peut par exemple servir
à montrer qu'on possède plusieurs territoires.
S'il s'agit d'armoiries personnelles, il peut
s'agir d'un regroupement de familles.
Les lignes de partition ne sont pas forcément
droites: elles peuvent être par exemple
crénelées,
dentelées, engrelées, ondoyées, potencées...
Jusqu'ici, si on devait blasonner cet écu
par exemple, on commencerait par décrire
les divisions du champ, la forme de la ligne
si elle n'est pas droite, puis les couleurs
en commençant en haut à dextre.
On a donc un blason parti sur fond or.
Enfin, viennent les meubles.
C'est à dire toutes les pièces qu'on va
rajouter sur nos armoiries.
Il y a déjà les petites pièces sympas et
pas compliquées à dessiner: croix, chevrons,
bordures, bandes, barres, bâton péri en
bande, fasce, sautoir, chef...
Bon, je vais pas toutes les citer parce qu'il
y en a un paquet.
Passons au meilleur: les animaux! Jusqu'au
XVIe siècle ce sont les principales figures
employées, même si on trouve ensuite des
objets inanimés.
On trouve les animaux classiques que vous
avez forcément déjà vus: l'aigle, le
cerf, le sanglier...
CF Game of Thrones pour la liste complète.
Parmi eux le lion est très répandu, pour
son caractère noble et féroce: c'est le
roi des animaux! Il peut avoir des positions
spécifiques: on parle de lion passant,
couché, accroupi, de lionceaux s'il y en
a trois ou plus...
Parfois on lui fait porter des couronnes,
des colliers, voire même des attributs chimériques
comme des ailes.
Ses griffes et sa langue sont toujours rouges.
Sauf si le fond est rouge, dans ce cas elles
sont souvent bleues et il devrait consulter
un véto.
Par contre, comme je le disais pour la Normandie,
si le lion vous regarde droit dans les yeux:
c'est un léopard!
Certaines armoiries représentent aussi des
êtres monstrueux, comme la mandragore dans
l'héraldique anglaise, la sirène, Mélusine,
le centaure, le sphinx égyptien ou le sphinx
grec, et enfin l'homme-sirène et la manticore,
qui sont plus rares en héraldique.
Et dans la vraie vie aussi.
Enfin perso, j'en ai jamais croisé.
Enfin, la dernière catégorie d'animaux correspond
aux animaux chimériques: l'antilope est
par exemple une invention anglaise représentant
un dragon rampant avec une armure de cerf
et sans ailes.
On voit que les gars connaissaient pas trop
l'Afrique.
On trouve aussi le dragon, qui a des ailes
en Angleterre mais pas en France: en France,
le dragon ailé est en fait un amphiptère!
Oui, c'est une erreur courante.
Il y a aussi le phénix, la salamandre, l'éale
et la licorne trop choupie.
Encore une fois cette liste est non exhaustive,
les possibilités de mélanges d'animaux et
de meubles à utiliser sont très nombreuses.
Il y a aussi le griffon par exemple.
Lui, c'est le roi de toutes les créatures:
parce que le lion est le roi des animaux,
l'aigle et le roi des oiseaux, et le griffon
est un mélange des deux.
D'ailleurs, en héraldique seule la femelle
a des ailes.
Le mâle a des défenses et des piques sur
le dos, parce que c'est plus BADASS.
Il y a aussi des termes particuliers si les
animaux ont des becs, des griffes et des cornes
par exemple: on dit qu'ils sont «armés».
Ils peuvent aussi être «adossés» s'ils
se font dos, ou «affrontés» s'ils se
font face, et si leur queue passe sous leur
ventre, ils sont couards! Ils peuvent aussi
être à deux ou trois corps, ou encore «coupés»
ou «arrachés» si des lambeaux de chair
pendent, bon appétit.
En plus des animaux, les meubles courants
du début de l'héraldique peuvent être des
fleurs, comme le lis, la rose ou le chardon;
ou encore quelques objets inanimés tels que
les tours, ponts, châteaux et autres bâtiments.
Voilà, je n'ai pas listé tous les termes
mais une bonne partie: maintenant vous allez
pouvoir blasonner dès que vous verrez des
armoiries, je compte sur vous.
Comme les armoiries sont héréditaires, les
fils de notre seigneur lambda, appelons-le
Jacqouille, ajoutent des petits meubles aux
armes initiales pour se différencier.
On appelle ces ajouts des brisures.
Parce que ça lui les brise haha.
Lorsque le fils aîné atteint la majorité
il ajoute des brisures, et quand son père
meurt il vire les brisures: maintenant c'est
lui le patron.
S'il meurt, son frère suivant peut à son
tour virer ses brisures et devenir le nouveau
chef de famille.
Imaginons maintenant que notre ami Jacqouille
n'a que des filles: si elles ne se marient
pas, elles peuvent quand même porter ses
armes jusqu'à leur mort, et ça c'est classe.
Si l'une des filles se marie, son mari peut
ajouter les armes de la famille Jacqouille
aux siennes: on appelle ça le «relèvement
d'armes». C'est surtout ce cas de figure
qui amène à des divisions toujours plus
compliquées, en partis, puis quartiers, puis
encore plus de quartiers...
Aux XVIIe et XVIIIe siècle surtout, ça devient
la mode de représenter toutes les alliances
et ascendances possibles, c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on parle de quartiers de noblesse,
et ça devient donc le bordel.
Par exemple le Stowe Armorial, peint en 1806
pour Richard Temple-Grenville, est un exemple
d'arme surcomposée.
En revanche si les filles de Jacqouille ne
se marient qu'avec des types qui n'avaient
pas d'armoiries, en théorie c'est mort, elle
pourra pas les transmettre.
Dans la pratique, ça se fait quand même
un peu.
Enfin un homme qui assure une fonction particulière,
évêque par exemple, peut combiner les armes
de sa fonction et les siennes, et s'il fait
partie d'un ordre et peut ajouter un petit
bandeau avec la devise de son ordre sous ses
armoiries.
Bon, c'était bien compliqué pour toi, mais
si vous devez retenir l'essentiel: l'héraldique,
c'est compliqué, il y a plein de règles,
et tout autant d'exceptions.
En faisant mes recherches, j'ai même appris
que le collège des Armes d'Angleterre avait
publié un texte de loi en 2014 relatif à
la transmission des armoiries dans le cadre
d'un mariage entre deux personnes de même
sexe.
Au fil des siècles les armoiries ne se limitent
plus seulement aux chevaliers et à la noblesse:
des femmes, des clercs, des bourgeois, voire
même artisans ou des paysans s'en font aussi.
Les armoiries deviennent également utilisées
pour représenter des corporations de métiers,
des communautés religieuses, des universités
ou des villes.
Pourtant l'héraldique a perdu son usage initial,
puisqu'à partir du XIVe siècle avec l'invention
de la poudre les armures tombent en désuétude:
elles ne font plus trop le poids face aux
projectiles des armes à feu, et donc les
combattants sont de nouveau identifiables
sans armoiries sur le champ de bataille.
Leur rôle initial a disparu pour devenir
un symbole de reconnaissance à l'attention
de l'ensemble de la société, et plus seulement
lors des tournois.
Par exemple, une récompense possible d'un
monarque envers un de ses sujets était d'
«augmenter» ses armoiries en y ajoutant
un élément.
Perso j'ai vu mieux comme récompense, mais
si ça leur faisait plaisir...
On va même créer des armoiries imaginaires
pour des personnages qui n'ont rien à voir
avec tout ça; ceux qui vivaient avant l'apparition
des armoiries par exemple: Alexandre, Jules
César ou Charlemagne; ou encore pour des
personnes qui ne font même pas partie de
l'occident chrétien: Attila a eu ses armoiries,
eh oui.
On en invente pour des personnages issus de
la mythologie gréco-romaine, ou de la mythologie
scandinave, des personnages bibliques, littéraires
comme Roland, le roi Arthur...
Et si vous croisez un jour quelqu'un portant
ces armoiries: fuyez, c'est Satan.
Bref tout le monde a ses armoiries, c'est
merveilleux, et puisque c'est comme ça moi
aussi j'en veux.
Voilà.
De sinople et d'or accompagné d'un orque
sable et argent.
Ça en jette ou pas?
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode et pour
le mois de mai je libérerai Aliénor de son
placard pour réaliser à nouveau un épisode
de Chroniques de Prof.
En attendant on se retrouve sur les réseaux
sociaux, et d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas
suivi sur ces réseaux sociaux je serai au
festival Les Historiques de Montbazon cet
été, les 22-23 juillets, vous retrouverez
les informations après ou dans la description.
Et ça va être bien.
A bientôt!